hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review i have a hopefully short
video today on
some of my uh test methodologies for uh
testing interference in cables uh
specifically for maintenance uh
interference if you look at the
you know marketing material for a lot of
interconnect cables or speaker cables
they claim how much noise immunity they
have and as a result that opens up the
sound and darker backgrounds and all
that stuff of course they never sorry
about the noise power cable though that
i need for the demo at any rate they uh
of course they don't show you any
measurements uh nor are there any
industry standard measurements for uh
for that kind of interference uh frankly
should
no it's mostly voodoo and nonsense so
it's not like a whole bunch of proper
engineers are gonna sit around and say
how do we test that um so i have to come
up with my own methods of testing these
claims and one of the methods i use is
very simple and let me take up this ac
cable
and i take an ac cable and bring it near
an interconnect cable and i've done this
test with
some expensive cables and when i do this
it actually picks up interference from
this when i do it on
you know this cheap amazon basics cable
i'll show you in a second it doesn't do
that so
uh it is an effective test i've
developed is ad hoc
you know it's but then again how you lay
your ac cables and you know
interconnects your home is also ad hoc
and
so it shows us stuff if x cable that
claims to have less interference
actually has more then we know that the
testing method is is effective i use
other methods sometimes i hook up a
transformer to this sometimes i loop
this around the other wire
i do enough things to get a rise out of
a cable and if neither cable shows it
then i ditch the test
recently this has come up people saying
whoa this this is not causing any
interference uh even though the other
side's plugged into ac this side is not
plugged to plugged into anything there's
no current flowing and therefore there
can't be any interference
so let me show you that
that that patent is false i'm going to
use what is called a
non-contact voltage tester
or ncv that electricians use and look at
what happens as i get close to this
cable it starts to beep i'm an inch away
two three centimeters away and it's
already detecting it and and uh when i
go away it goes away and when i get
close it picks it up again so clearly
something's happening and it's going
through air and is getting coupled into
this thing
now
what is this and how does it work uh if
you look at the end all you see is uh i
don't know if you can see but all you
see is this little piece of metal in
there and there's nothing else just that
piece of metal and goes inside and
there's an amplifier circuit that
amplifies the voltage that's coming
across from this and
the question is then how does a circuit
get formed
so
let's start at the beginning uh when i
bring this near here and actually
interesting thing is happening there's
metal there's water conductors in here
right there metal and there's metal in
here and when i bring the two together
they form what is called a capacitor a
capacitor is an electric electronic
device that uh likes ac but doesn't like
dc so if i bring this next to a battery
it does nothing but if i bring it next
to this other wire a capacitor is formed
and a capacitor will then carry on the
ac waveform that's on this
into this device now that ac waveform is
very weak and hence the amplifiers that
have to be in here
but your audio devices also have
amplification in them so you know that
gain also exists in your audio products
now as i bring this this is not the end
of this story so now we have a capacitor
which means some amount of this voltage
is going to transfer to this but if you
have a circuit with one side of it open
it does nothing
because you have to complete the circuit
the light bulb does not come on if you
just connect one side of it to a power
source it needs to have the other side
also plugged in so what then happens is
that it's going through my body my body
actually has a certain impedance and
then my body couples to ground and that
ground travels all the way back to the
electrical meter where it's uh
completes the circuit so the hot wire
goes through this as a via a capacitor
invisible capacitor and a circuit is uh
completed now this is an electronic
explanation there's also electromagnetic
field
explanation in that
this is generating both
electrical radiation and magnetic
radiation the electromagnetic field we
call it and the electric field is
created via a
voltage
magnetic field is created via current so
the fact that this is not carrying
current right now actually is carrying a
little bit of current but let's put that
aside the fact that there's no current
it doesn't matter it's not material
because the the electric field is active
and that capacitor is able to pick that
up and convey it into this or in field
theory this is actually coupling to this
and
so the notion that this test is useless
doesn't work because it obviously i just
showed you how there is something coming
off of this cable without it this end
hooked up to something
the other end is of course very
important hooked up to an ac outlet
i said that there is actually a little
bit of current going on because if you
look at the end of this uh ic cable you
see that the two conductors are in here
and between them there's an insulator
and that that again forms a capacitor
and that capacitor actually completes
the circuit from here to here and so
there's a little bit of current it's
also
generated or created in here and so this
is actually a closed loop it has an
impedance at 60 hertz and harmonics and
therefore current is
actually in this cable
now as an aside i went ahead did that
experiment on a forum where i put
current through this and same results
came out that just makes things you know
a little bit worse but in general just
don't think because something's
invisible or to lay
intuition is there's nothing here it's
just a disconnected cable no it's not a
disconnected cable it's connected over
there and it has one end of one leg of a
capacitor waiting to couple into
something else
so let me show you as a
experiment what that looks like in in
audio applications and
excuse me
so what i have in here is uh
amazon basics uh
interconnect i've hooked it up to the
input of the analyzer and it's just
dangling in the air and for the same
principles i just explained is actually
picking up uh mains interference so let
me get my cursor in here hopefully you
can see so in here we see the waveform
that is picking up is about 60 hertz i'm
holding it so again remember that
circuit is getting completed through my
body to the chassis uh to the earth and
going to the main uh to the breaker
panel and we see that the dominant
signal is 60 hers in here as indicated
in here so there's no question
that this is picking up interference ac
interference
with stuff just sitting around
now by the way the same thing happens if
you go back of your power amplifier and
you touch the input you hear that hum
and buzz
again you're completing a circuit
through your body
now
look at what happens if i take the red
cable and i pick up my old ac cable and
pay attention to the red signal on the
right
look at what happened there
i'm just bringing it close to this guy
notice that the red signal is now a lot
stronger than the uh
than the blue signal so absolutely we're
picking up interference and we're able
to do it
with a cable that's not hooked up to
anything isn't dangling in the air but
sure as heck is enough to give us about
a i said 10 to 15 db
coupling from this to this
now you might say whoa then i need those
fancy cables well maybe if they are
designed properly and i'll be doing the
opposite but look at what happens when i
plug this into the output of the
analyzer the analyze actually is not
sending any signal
uh but it has an impedance in this case
i think it's for tony home impedance and
the moment with i do that look at what
happened to the fft spectrum shrunk way
down you still see noise in here because
the analyze everything in the world has
noise but as it's below one micro
voltage noise so this is very very small
amount of noise but important if we look
at the spectrum on the right we don't
see that mainstream and that's how you
use your ac cables right you hook them
up to the input of your uh to the output
of your source device which has a low
impedance and the low impedance is the
enemy of that
uh electric field that i was talking
about because it shunts it basically and
doesn't allow hardly any current to
develop to get out get amplified indeed
you know i can well
not convenient but i can put this next
to this and you can see that it's not
doing anything
so the notion that you know the test was
done with the cable dangling in the air
means i think it just
shows in a sense a lack of understanding
of electromagnetic fields
and uh
frankly even engineers sometimes don't
understand this you know we get taught
all the stuff in school with no
connection to reality nobody does the
demonstration i just showed you so you
get you suffer through all the math and
proofs and everything and maxwell
equations and stuff and you happily put
it behind you unless you work in in rf
world and then this stuff becomes
mandatory that you and you go back and
learn it again
you know because the first time you had
no reason to remember it all but the
second time you absolutely are motivated
to learn it so i actually can't even
blame engineers for not understanding
this concept and and ridiculing it that
you know an ac cable dangle in the air
uh cause any problems but if you've
designed any audio equipment you know
how bad these things can be you know you
get an ac cable next to some sensitive
input signal and boom you know it picks
up that whether that
ac cable is energized with much current
or not
and by the way a lot of your source
devices hardly consume any card uh your
cd player power cord
it or fcd player in the old days when we
had cd players only 10 20 30 watts of
power the current is in milliamps so
you know it doesn't matter and frankly
if you're going to try to sell cables
you don't want to dissuade people from
thinking that you know cable that
doesn't carry a lot of current is safe
you want to amp that up so the notion
that people say oh you know that was not
a good task go buy my cables it's like
no no no you want to be behind me lining
up saying there's interference of course
terrible for them is that i just
demonstrated once i terminate the input
you know the world's problems go away
the other thing to know is that when you
use unbalanced circus rca circuits
in real systems
with multiple pieces in them you almost
always get mains interference in here
whether internally or externally and
good news is that at low frequencies our
threshold of hearing is very high so
even though every system practically
with rca connections has a ground loop
or mains interference problems
99.99 percent of people don't hear them
because
you know we're just not sensitive to all
frequencies otherwise you know
rca connectors would have been outlawed
decades back
so we get away with it
on that so that's a side note hopefully
you like this shorter video let's see
it's 12 minutes still and i'll see you
in a future one i'll have a few more of
these quickies uh planned for other
concepts similar to this okay see you in
a future one bye